on the moon where the sun shining it's
blindingly bright
where isn't it's pitch black the surface
is covered in the finest particles of
sand
it's tricky environment for even the
most advanced machines to navigate and
before fleets of these things start
roaming the real moon this engineer has
many late nights ahead perfecting this
Rover and testing it on an artificial
landscape like this one will get us one
step closer to establishing the first
human settlement away from Earth one day
when you and I make it up to the moon
it could be thanks to her my name is a
canaima Maura and I built miniature
lunar rover
[Music]
I mean sa nobody open as I have no name
it what is he
[Music]
going to the moon used to be something
only the biggest governments dreamed of
but with the growing commercialization
of space some of the most exciting
projects now are taking place at
startups and today and back in my
hometown to visit one of them but if I
can do this I space got its start in
2010 as a group of engineers competing
for the 30 million dollar Google Lunar
XPrize the competition expired last year
without a winner but having raised more
than 90 million dollars from Japan's
government-backed funds and companies
including Japan Airlines I space is now
focused on becoming a business in its
own right so this is a rover yeah this
isn't over
my space Deva don't ski no Mizuho
mitsuketa so narrow scott atarashi kids
I cannot skin it's good order to follow
they adore robotic I had the random look
I had such Dima so they got moon banana
ah someone is me when you think of a
space rover you might think of the moon
buggy used in three of the Apollo
missions or the opportunity Rover that
looked for water on Mars
next to these two hulking creations from
previous decades I space this machine is
so small it looks like a toy oh you know
yeah
Akane steam is racing against their
deadline of 2021 when a SpaceX rocket
will blast ice bases Lander carrying two
Rovers into orbit around the moon after
a soft landing
each Rover will roll out and roam the
lunar landscape sending images video and
mapping data back to earth
on the development robe our recession
mass tomorrow a kinase team will take
one big step forward they're gonna be
taking these two prototypes to a fakemon
skin no human the record is the sukhovka
nose knowledge essential Matsumoto is
named the SAC amici roncada so okay so
deep we are saying Akane is responsible
for the structural elements of the rover
and that involves everything from
choosing the best physical materials to
make a lightweight but still resilient
machine to the thorny challenge of
designing the shape of these wheels
kono Takas ah no oh no no no kimochi no
robot Erika no cry no haider al-abadi
wounded deer normal to lead on a potato
otário Desiree oh gee so the toad a toad
a tuxedo
turnover economist
[Music]
Oh
early the next morning we made our way
to the suburbs outside Tokyo give you a
kiss - no energy king at the guillotine
and orders
[Music]
a lot about the kind of son no okay I
was broken I have to show up for
something
and once the city's high-rises gave way
to smaller neighborhoods we reached our
destination the Japan aerospace
exploration agency known as JAXA here on
earth this is the closest thing to the
moon we have an hour an hour and a half
of REO testing in this morning with both
rubbery and Wilbur be doing their tests
in parallel make sure that we're logging
and backing up all the data ok I gotta
kiss them or I'm a scar
beside mascara no more no get to manage
or tie your motor stainless don't know
when you come in about ten Sayaka Moraga
so no image your scooty does Carter know
I hardly sit to discuss I again did you
know their demo get so much guidance you
know get to make this right
no Chuck taco taco taco a coma or mother
died oh no kita
and after a few final preparations they
started the tests oh my gosh
[Music]
a first was a series of 10 meter crawls
along flat ground with every run akane
steam reconfigured the rover to have a
different weight distribution
the plan was to see which versions would
be able to run straight I'll give this a
measure how much the rogue ones would be
your off path I was gonna thank you my
stop
[Music]
and then it was the hardest part of the
day
the lunar hill climbs and with the
chance to play a very tiny role in
establishing humanity's presence on the
moon I couldn't resist
with my super vocal commando
Oh with the my likeness just oh yes the
entire site
[Music]
Obama famously vomit Amazo comedy Sokka
me chinga su casa rosada Gio Naruto
caranesca the world Karamoja each table
over I stop
you can wash that dear future lunar
residents and lunar tourists you're
welcome did I'll shine get skipped in
there
my by for about two days a week
Akane works from home why must I scan -
you're staying this day on there and
it's this flexibility but scepter
balance a job as daunting is building a
space rover with another equally
demanding responsibility go to dr. Gaza
but in a country that has one of the
developed world's worst records on
gender inequality
akane success is still rare and even for
her a pretty recent development
[Music]
Akane has a master's in mechanical
engineering and her first stop out of
school involved research on concrete and
later on metals at a big prestigious
Japanese manufacturer she was one of
very few female engineers in an R&D
department dominated by men
we're totally the touch cooking more
stylish there behind Athena Watson
because I not take de Soto
now Kakashi Otto's demo at sky nico a
meeting in addition man that the kanji
done this know what does she got a she
Nico Mariano say God's character she's
in the kanji or boy Tomas don't like him
what she has done several times
Akane considered quitting work
altogether and becoming a full-time
housewife while her husband pursued his
career ethical ginseng dr. kacica
it was said to me at this in my soul at
last day so that I could know a man do
you st. action yes I should take me
another person a mom again
in 2017
akane join i space as a spacecraft
structure engineer the hectic nature of
life at a start-up has come with its own
challenges but in a company that's
attracted young people from countries
like France the US and Canada she says
she's a lot happier now
Auto 90 nautical on you are she shook
Sudoku knew I knew homodimer caught
their to it is also listened to attach
to not even and I am your mother moon I
took my name is Amelia
[Music]
so the desk in accout ova1 Tony say by
tequila bar sorry we are touched this
year was it this way nobody know to get
Manasa the soil or the Taco Bell Karuma
girl over there are lots good day to
mama
[Music]
I space predicts it city on the moon
will be ready in 2040 by then with an
estimated one trillion dollar global
space industry to serve we'll have a
whole generation of engineers building
machines to explore the moon Mars and
beyond
now that they've successfully completed
their field tests Akane and her
co-workers have been busy analyzing all
the data they collected so they can
start designing the next iteration of
the rover their first true milestone
will be the rover's launch day in two
years time kakarotto vidas de mama de
que esta koto mo Nino de Dona imagine
generic Econoline desu kedo yet many
know NATO mission a kendama quick car to
know the king Johto condo to handle
karana
Thomas
[Music]
you